Kaitlyn Bristowe and Shawn booth attend
a wedding but when is theirs hi guys i'm
lauren zima and as a big bachelorette
fan i am dying to know when will Kaitlyn
and Shawn get hitched already and it
looks like Kaitlyn knows that we all
really want to know she just posted this
photo to Instagram it's her and Shawn at
a wedding where she was a bridesmaid she
jokingly captioned it OMG get married
already yes this super sexy couple seems
to do just about everything together
they just got back from a vacation in
Hawaii where they went paddleboarding
swam with sharks took a helicopter tour
golfed enjoyed date nights just about
everything except setting a wedding date
now I interviewed Kaitlyn and Shawn at
Jade and Tanner's wedding back in
January here's the update they gave me
on wedding plans back then we're so bad
at planning both of us together so we're
like yeah we'll do in the new year when
you guys do get married have you talked
about would you do a televised event or
what do you envision it as yeah we we
thought it would be fun do one we don't
rule it out we're just if it happens it
happens if it doesn't it doesn't Kaitlyn
is actually my all-time favorite
Bachelorette but who is yours I want to
know let me know on twitter i'm at
lauren zima